ein spaziergang mit einem dessen
sexuelle präferenz manch anderem zum
verbrecher werden lässt der 29 jährige
max weber heißt in wirklichkeit anders
real ist aber seine pädophile neigung
seit der pubertät fühlt er sich zu
kindern hingezogen mit 20 wurde ihm klar
dass irgendetwas mit ihm nicht stimmt
wir festgestellt dass ich wechseln nicht
nur auf form ausgerichteten soll ihn
auch auf kindliche mädchen altersgruppe
zwischen sechs und elf jahren
es wird unglaublich inneres zither eine
innere unruhe nicht zu wissen was ist da
in einem drin
wer bin ich was bin ich was will ich
eigentlich will ich kinder mitfahren
jeder tag ist für max weber eine neue
herausforderung seine sexualität darf er
niemals aus leben eine innere
zerrissenheit die für ihn irgendwann
unerträglich wird also erste punkt ist
sagen wir dass es anfang die banken zu
häufen wie daran sie im geiste
auszuziehen oder anfügen dass das denken
zu bestimmen wann ich dann aber kam dass
es gefährlich komponente hat oder hier
drin einzige trude und nein das darf ich
das kann ich sein und muss weg und warum
wir das sich auf hilfe hat max weber
hier gefunden in einem
präventionsprojekt bietet die berliner
universitätsklinik charité menschen mit
pädophiler neigung an sich therapieren
zu lassen
im internet und mit einem fernsehspot
sucht das institut potenzielle täter aus
dem dunkelfeld das heißt sie sollten
zuvor noch nicht straffällig geworden
seien
schon früher habe ich gemerkt dass ich
anders ticke war schon klar wie man über
solche wie mich denkt krank herbert
abschaum dachte es ja auch dabei habe
ich meine fantasie noch nie ausgelegt
durch die therapie habe ich gelernt
niemand ist schuld an seiner sexuellen
neigung aber jeder verantwortlich für
sein verhalten
ich will kein täter werden um kein täter
zu werden müssen kursteilnehmer lernen
ihre sexualität nur in der fantasie
auszuleben auch der konsum von
kinderpornografie ist für sie tabu
dabei helfen sollen sexual psychologen
wie christian ahlers der das projekt
kein täter werden aufgebaut hat ein jahr
lang behandelte er max weber in einer
gruppentherapie mit erfolg auch wenn
pädophilie als nicht heilbar gilt von
denen die an einer solchen therapie
teilnehmen geht strukturell ein
geringeres risiko aus als von solchen
die kein problembewusstsein haben und
die sich einer solchen therapie nicht
stellen
man braucht hier auch mut und
selbstvertrauen dazu sich überhaupt an
eine solche institution zu wenden
eine institution die auch peter
bringmann hanseller unterstützt als kind
wurde er selbst jahrelang von einem
pfarrer missbraucht
heute spricht er für die
bundesinitiative der betroffenen von
sexualisierter gewalt und missbrauch wir
müssen an das eigentliche problem heran
und da ist es sinnvoll wenn man den
tätern auch eine möglichkeit gibt sich
vor einer tat zu melden weil sie das
gefühl haben sie befassen sich mit
kindern oder wollen gerne was mit kinder
machen
das ist in unseren augen der
präventionsarbeit die sehr sinnvoll ist
in seiner therapie hat max weber gelernt
sich in die opfer hineinzuversetzen
kinder auf distanz zu halten so viel
nähe gar nicht erst zuzulassen was aus
ihnen ohne behandlung geworden wäre
darüber kann er nur spekulieren ich
denke mal gespannt wie gut dass ich es
geschafft wird niemals miss vorzugehen
ich muss allerdings gestehen dass die
wahrnehmungs verzierungen
also was die waren auch bei mir da und
hätten durchaus situationen welchen
situationen wo schlagen und möchte zu
den gedanken verleiten können ja das ist
ja nicht missbrauch das muss den kindern
ich schreiben mache ich das mache
und ich bin nicht sicher
dank der therapie hat max weber seine
fantasien bislang unter kontrolle wie er
sagt seine pädophile neigung jedoch die
bleibt für immer